Well, Robert, it's so great to be with
you today, and what we're covering on
the program is three reasons why
Muhammad doesn't exist. So, let's jump
right in. What is your first reason? Uh
the sources that give us the
biographical information about him are
all so late, several hundred year, 200
years and following after his the time
of his alleged life that uh there was
plenty of time for legendary material to
enter in, and we cannot know actually
anything for certain about this man.
Okay. So, are you referring to the
Hadith? That's right.
Okay. And we don't have it is your view
that we don't have any other sources
outside of the Hadith about his life?
Well, there's the Sira literature, but
that's just got the same problem. The
Hadith and Sira literature all date from
the beginning of the 9th century, and
people point out that they are dependent
upon earlier works that have been lost
that were written as if that were
probative of something, but the fact is
we have works that were written that
survive.
For example, Ibn Sa'd and Waqidi,
who date from roughly around the same
time in the 9th century with Waqidi
being a little bit later, and he shows a
tremendous amount of legendary
elaboration in the stories that he
shares with Ibn Sa'd. So, in other
words, if you have the that kind of
legendary elaboration in written
literature, in material that both dates
from the 9th century, then it's
reasonable to surmise and conclude that
in the material that we have that's no
longer extant, there was also legendary
elaboration to the degree that while
there may have been some person around
whom these legends began to be attached,
we can't know anything about him.
>> [snorts]
>> Did you also make the point in your
debate with David that in the Hadith
literature, there was already it's
already known that there were legendary
stories about Muhammad, and most of them
were sort of like weeded out? Yeah,
that's actually my second reason. And
so, we can move on to that. The
sources themselves, the Muslim sources
that give us the Hadith literature, tell
us that the material that they are
conserving and presenting to us is the
result of a tremendous winnowing process
in which they declared inauthentic a
massive number of accounts of Muhammad's
words and deeds. For example, Bukhari.
Sahih Bukhari is supposed to be the
Hadith collection that is most reliable.
As a matter of fact, that's what Sahih
means, reliable. And so, when Muslims
refer to the Hadith, they are most often
referring to Bukhari. And when they
refer to Bukhari, they are referring to
something that Muslims will generally
take as reliable.
So, it's considered to be an extremely
important source.
Now, Bukhari is somebody who here again
lived in the 9th century, and he is said
to have traveled all around the Islamic
world gathering Hadiths, gathering
traditions about Muhammad, and he
ultimately gathered together 600,000 of
them, and then rejected 593,000
of those, 593,000
as forged, and kept the 7,000.
And so, when we have that number of
forgeries,
it is once again extremely difficult to
sort out what is authentic from what
isn't. And
in the course of Bukhari's
investigations,
when he decided that these 7,000 were
authentic, he did so on the basis of
criteria that nobody can really honestly
accept as establishing that the stories
are authentic versus the others that he
rejected. And that leads to the third
point. Now, I know you wanted to go on
elaborate about this for quite some
time, and I'm giving you all three at
the beginning, but there's plenty that
can that can be said about this. We
won't run out of material. And
>> Okay. No, I was actually going to ask
you what that criteria was, and so maybe
it just makes sense to go ahead and get
into that third one, and then and then
have some back and forth.
>> Great. The third uh point is that the
criteria used in traditional Islam to
determine which stories of Muhammad are
authentic and which are not are based on
something that is inherently no more
reliable than the stories themselves,
and that is the isnad chains, the chains
of transmission. Every Hadith has a matn
and an isnad. The matn is the story
itself.
If you go in the if you go to sunna.com,
for example, you can't see this in the
English. They don't usually put the
matns translate the matns, but if you if
you click onto the Arabic, you can see
that every story has the the I mean,
they usually don't give you the isnad,
sorry. I said that backwards. The isnad
is what is not there. The matn, the
story, is there.
You click on the Arabic, and you also
see the matn. Um the isnad Doing it
again. I'm sorry. Very tired these days.
You click on the Arabic, you also see
the isnad, which is the chain of
transmission that Aisha said that she
heard this from Muhammad, and so-and-so
heard it from Aisha, and so-and-so heard
it from the first so-and-so, and on and
on and on to the person who's recording
it.
Now, the earliest matns, the earliest
stories, had no isnad. They had no chain
of transmission listed.
The earliest extant stories of Muhammad
did not tell us who originated them and
who was passing them on. But the
standard criteria are that one has to
have an unbroken chain, and every person
in the chain needs to be reliable.
If somebody in the chain is known not to
be so honest or careful with the facts,
then that chain becomes suspect. Or if
somebody so-and-so heard it from another
guy, but then we don't know who heard it
from so-and-so who brought it on to our
own age, then it's not or to the age in
which it's being written down, then it's
not reliable. But the thing is, the
isnad chains are even date from even
later than the stories. And
they can just as easily be forged. If
you want to have a story that everybody
takes seriously, you load up your chain
with reliable people that everybody
loves. Done.
And there were numerous numerous stories
that have different chains of
transmission where it's clear that
people who later on had a sullied
reputation or something of that kind
were replaced with people with sterling
reputation because these stories were
they the various powers wanted them
repeated, wanted them to be considered
canonical.
So, do we have anything like this? I'm
always thinking of like paralleling this
with the the Christian account, okay,
that we have about Jesus. Do we have
anything like this with respect to the
genealogy in the the Gospels, you know,
could could they have just been making
those up as well? Is there time for
legendary development there? There could
have been.
And this, of course, is something that
many people have suggested throughout
history. And this is one thing that I
want to emphasize here at the beginning,
that historical evaluation of the
Gospels and the New Testament in general
has been going on for several centuries,
and Christians are not threatened by it.
And yet suddenly, when I start and some
other people start investigating
Muhammad historically and the origins of
Islam historically, everybody gets
upset. And I find that odd. But in any
case, to the to the question itself, we
have in Matthew and Luke, we have two
separate genealogies of Jesus. Now,
there are various explanations posited
for that, that one is Joseph's, one is
Mary's, they are both made up, they are
competing
different versions of the same thing
with divergences of detail, things like
that. Now, we don't really know
ultimately what the story is when it
comes to those, but we do know some
general principles. And that is that the
Gospels were written within the
lifetimes of people who knew Jesus and
listened to him.
And that is an extremely different
situation from what you have with the
Hadith literature, where it all starts
to be written down 200 years after
Muhammad.
You have in the first 60 years of
Christianity, you have the establishment
of churches all around the Mediterranean
area. You have the Epistles of St. Paul
and of St. Peter and James and John and
so on. You have the the
post-canonical writings of St. Clement
at the toward the end of the 1st century
and others. At the beginning of the
second, you have St. Ignatius of
Antioch, who is said to have been
the little child that Jesus puts in the
midst of the people when he's talking at
one point and uh
whether he was or not, clearly he lived
he was old enough in the year 107 when
he wrote his letters that he could have
been somebody who knew the apostles, one
or more.
And uh you have various others. You Now,
you have
in all those writings
a many great many references to the
Lord,
met references to what he said and to
what he did. You have non-Christians
talking about what he said and what he
did. So, you take the same 60-year
period in the 7th century for Muhammad
and you have an extremely different
situation.
You have the Quran, but you have not all
of it and you have
Excuse me, some indication
from scholars such as Christoph
Luxenberg and others that there may have
been an Urtext, a text that the Quran is
based upon
that was extant before the Quran.
So, you have the question of that. You
have the fact that in the Quran itself
anyway, there's only four mentions of
Muhammad by name
and none of those contain any
biographical information.
You have a few mentions of Muhammad by
non-Muslims, but you have uh
none of them actually corresponding to
the standard story of Muhammad as we
have it today and as it is formulated in
the Hadiths and the Sira literature in
the 9th century.
So, this is very strange. People say,
"Well, you know, there's there's a lot
of slippage in history." And I've heard
people say this recently amid the
late controversies about these issues.
And then you can't expect everybody to
get everything right. And that's that's
certainly true, but you might expect
somebody to get something right.
And yet none of them do.
And uh you also have a uh
tremendous absence
of attestation from 7th-century people
who encountered the Arabs
that there's scant mention of Muhammad
and no mention of the Quran or Islam.
Why not? Why the big secret when later
on it becomes the most important thing
that they've got to say to anybody in
[clears throat] any context at any
point?
So, all this makes us think maybe these
things didn't exist yet and this is why
nobody mentions them.
Isn't it also true, I've heard Jay Smith
talk about this, that the of the
mentions in the Quran, cuz in the
original version, the Uthmanic text, um
it it lacks the dots and the slashes.
>> Yeah. Is that correct? And so when it
mentions Muhammad, it could be referring
to someone else? Is that true?
>> Well, it's not neces- it's not
those two things don't necessarily go
together. The The thing is this, that
in the first place, Arabic
the Arabic language has 22 letters, the
alphabet. And 16 of those letters are
identical
they they are they have another letter
that looks just like them.
There are only six that are unique in
their shape.
And the way that you distinguish those
the ones that look just like one other
or one or more others is by the
diacritical marks, the dots that go
above or below the letter.
So, you have for example this
shape. It's not very easy to do. I I
didn't bring flashcards, but in any
case, you have this kind of looks like
an L backwards. And you put a dot over
it, you put a dot under it, you put two
dots and it's different letters.
So, the earliest
Qurans do not have any of those
diacritical marks. And so people can
not be entirely sure that the text is
actually saying
what they think that it says. I'll give
you uh actually
a a famous example
that is
uh spread as a is repeated as a joke,
but it actually contains a very
important point. In chapter
two, verse two, right at the beginning
of the Quran, chapter two, verse two.
This book, there is no doubt in it.
All right? Now, doubt is raiba.
But oil is zaita.
And the letters R and Z
are the same except for the diacritical
marks. And the letters B and T are the
same except for the diacritical marks.
And so there's a famous story about a
kid reading the Quran out early on in
the life of Islam and he says, "This
book, there's no oil in it."
And that is a actually quite reasonable
thing to think the book is saying when
you do not have something specifying
which letter is meant.
And so what I think you're referring to
when you're when you're talking about in
the first place what Jay Smith says is
the fact that the Quranic text is far
more indeterminate than most people
realize because of the slippage caused
by the lack of the diacritical marks in
the earliest manuscripts. But what Jay
is referring to there is the fact that
uh all the Arabic words are based on
consonants. And you have marks that show
the vowels. And the earliest Quranic
manuscripts don't have those either.
And when you're talking about Muhammad
you you have M H M D,
but when you strip away the vowels, it
could be that somebody else is being
referred to altogether, yes. And when
the word is used, it has a meaning,
Muhammad, the praised one.
And so some people have posited that
these four mentions of Muhammad in the
Quran that contain no biographical
information are actually the usages of a
title, the praised one, that could refer
to any number of other people.
Mhm. Yeah, so that was my one of my
deepest questions was about the Quran
itself mentioning Muhammad and then the
the deeper question about the
What is it? Diacritical marks.
diacritical marks and
whether or not that leaves open
alternate interpretations. And then you
you're you're almost Well, all three
reasons involved the Hadith, right?
These sort of later mentions about
Muhammad that the the biographical
information is sort sort of too far
removed. What about um
His name is is slipping my mind right
now. That What What is the one of the
earliest Christian writers that that
spoke about Muhammad?
>> about John John of Damascus?
Yes. Um Saint John of Damascus. What
Okay, so here's here's a theory.
What if there was no Muhammad depicted
by the Hadith literature or the Sira
literature. There was no such person
that matched all that criteria.
However, there was a person that matched
the sort of earlier sources that we have
from Saint John of Damascus and some of
these earlier non non Muslim writers.
There was some person named Muhammad
that did some things along those lines.
Would you be open to a theory like that?
Yeah. Or would you still say no? Well,
see, this is where we have to define
what we mean by
those no Muhammad.
And that is a statement that can
actually admit of numerous different
interpretations.
And the one that I favor is not to say
there was never any such person.
There could have been such a person.
There could even have been a warrior
prophet because some of the earliest
mentions non-Muslim mentions of Muhammad
are of a warrior prophet. And a warrior
prophet is certainly what he was.
At the same time, the Muhammad of Islam
who says and does so very many things
in the Hadith and about whom we know so
much because of the Hadith, that man did
not exist. 100%.
There is no record of such a person in
the 7th century. Now, you may say you're
just splitting hairs because if you have
a warrior prophet, it could have been
this guy. Well, yeah, could have been.
Or it may have been that he's made up
based on the
bare fact of the of the understanding
that there had been such a warrior
prophet at this time and all these
legends got attached to him.
Um looking for John of Damascus.
John of Damascus is uh
aware
of the um
Quran
and yet he seems to not have the Quran
that we have now.
Mhm. Because he says that he's read
all their frivolous tales, the the
Muslims, including the text of the
woman, the text of the cow, the text of
the table, and the text of the camel of
God. Now,
all of those except the camel of God are
chapters of the Quran.
But he doesn't say the Quran, he says
he's read these texts.
They may be four separate books, the
woman, the the table, the cow, and the
camel of God. He doesn't he he he
doesn't give the impression that they're
one book, but we can say, "Okay, maybe
they're one book." But even if they're
one book,
the camel of God is referred to in the
Quran several times and it's kind of
elliptical. It's not really very clear
what he what is meant by it. But, there
is no text, there is no chapter of the
camel of God. And so, it seems as if the
Quran to which John had access, if he
had access to the Quran at all, and not
to these separate books as as separate
writings,
it was not the one we have.
The standard narrative is that Uthman,
as you mentioned, collected the Quran in
the year 653
and standardized the text, burnt all the
variants, and delivered it to the
provinces, so that the Quran must should
have been standard after that.
According to the standard story. So,
John, 75 years later, he's got the
Quran. Why should he have a different
one? And yet, he does.
And so,
the Quran seems the standard story of
the formation of the Quran seems also to
not be historical and to have been
retrojected back into history to the
time of Uthman, but there isn't any
evidence at the actual time of Uthman
or up to the time of John of Damascus
that such a book actually existed
in its present form.
So, I I another sort of objection that I
was thinking about was, you know, within
the different Christian denominations,
there's a lot of different views about
Jesus,
right? There's
and some of these differences are are
are rather large. Like, suppose that you
want to count Unitarians as as
Christians. Okay?
In that case, you've got like every
Christian, no matter what sect or no
matter what denomination, is going to
agree that there was a historical figure
named Jesus, right? But, they differ
they there's lots of wide disagreement
about what sort of
uh characteristics or properties that
this person had. So, maybe is that
could that be going on with Muhammad?
So, for example, most Muslims today
think that the Hadith literature is
reliable and we can know a lot of
information about Muhammad, but maybe
they're just wrong. Maybe maybe those
properties don't actually sort of map on
to Muhammad, just like the Unitarians
are wrong, right? Those properties that
they ascribe to Jesus don't map on don't
actually map on to Jesus. Nevertheless,
there was a historical person named
Jesus. And so, maybe even if the Hadith
literature is unreliable, maybe there
still was a historical person named
Muhammad. Because otherwise, what is the
hypothesis here? What what sort of
hypothesis are we putting forward? Is
your is your view that there were
there there was a growing movement and
I I it's hard for me to even make sense
of how the whole religion even got off
the ground if there was no individual
person that, you know, supposedly
received this
revelation from from Allah or whatever.
So, what what is your Maybe that's a
better way of asking my question. What
what is your competing hypothesis with
the hypothesis that there was this sort
of historical person, even if the Hadith
is unreliable and those stories are not
true,
nevertheless, there was some some person
named Muhammad that sort of got all this
off the ground. What is your competing
hypothesis? Was
was it just like some some random group
of people that got together and just
made up this book completely out of
whole cloth or what exactly are you
putting forward here? All right, hold
on. Now, you've said an awful lot.
I did. I apologize. I I I and then I
kind of shifted my point toward the end.
Yeah, if if I could go back to the first
part, there's quite a lot to say about
that to start with. And then, we can get
to the the alternative theory. The
Unitarians in the first place, this is
not just an issue of differing
interpretations.
The different
>> [snorts]
>> sects of or denominations of
Christianity, for the most part, unless
you want to get into ones that are only
marginally or arguably Christian at all,
like the Jehovah's Witnesses or Mormons,
they don't have a different scripture.
They don't have a different New
Testament. The they just see it all
differently.
And so, that really is no analogy to
what we're talking about here because
the
question is not that uh
maybe there's a different set of sources
or different
uh
group of of of canonical texts that we
should refer to.
We all we're we all agree on what the
Hadiths are and what the Sira literature
are
is constituted by and what uh they say
Muhammad said and did.
The question is, where does all that
come from?
And
Muslims to this day will tell you that
they believe in Muhammad because they
believe that the Hadiths are reliable.
They believe that it's actually a
superior method of preserving material.
They say that the the New Testament, the
Gospels, they don't tell you the
the isnads. They don't tell you who told
you this stuff.
And so, you know,
they they they discount it on that
basis.
Now, that's true.
If their own construction of the sources
for their material were not so clearly
forged and fictional, that might have
more weight.
But,
that is the case that even by their own
admission, by the sources that they
themselves are citing,
we know that their material is
unreliable.
That a great a great deal of it was
forged, including the isnad chains, the
chains of transmission. So, when we talk
about Matthew, Mark, and Luke, and John,
and they say, "We don't even know where
these stories come from." And so on,
that what we fall back on the fact that
they were
circulating among the apostles at the
time the apostles were alive or many or
most of them were alive, and that many
of the followers of Jesus who had not
been apostles were alive, like the 500
who saw him at one time that Paul refers
to after the resurrection, and so on.
And so,
the stories that were inaccurate would
have been flagged
and rejected.
And so, we have these
four
collections of material that have the
approval of the community
in living memory of the founder. That's
that's sufficient. But, it's very
different from what we have in Islam.
Now, as far as what else might have
happened if you don't have Muhammad the
prophet of Islam,
Oh, well, I I I'm sorry. Just to repeat
the last
just to emphasize or conclude the last
bit. That's very different from
theological disagreements among the
followers of Jesus that arise centuries
later
and are all based on the same texts, but
different understandings of the same
texts. Anyway, in Islam,
the idea is this, that it's very clear
that
Islam arose in a monotheistic setting,
and the monotheism was already there.
And it was not, however,
extraordinarily well defined.
For example, Sophronius of Jerusalem,
the bishop of Jerusalem at the time of
the Arab conquest in the 630s,
writes extensively about the conquerors
and about the theological questions
raised by the fact that God would allow
his people to be overwhelmed and
defeated and and and in many cases
enslaved or killed by these people who
by these invaders.
And so,
it's noteworthy that Sophronius never
calls them Muslims
and never refers to Muhammad
and never
speaks about their having a new
religion.
But, he does say that they destroyed
churches and that they did so because
they considered them them idolatrous and
that they were calling people back to
the strict monotheism that they were
preaching.
And so, it seems like a curious omission
that Sophronius makes no mention of
Islam. And nobody else does either, for
that matter.
And it seems most reasonable to conclude
on that basis that there was no Islam at
that time, but there was a creedally
vague monotheism.
>> [snorts]
>> And that creedally vague monotheism
seems to have been related to
an understanding of Christianity that
may have come from Christian heretics
because we're talking about Arabia and
we're talking about southern Iraq and
those areas that were right outside the
boundaries of the Roman Empire, the
Christian Empire.
>> [snorts]
>> In those days, if you were a heretic,
you would be subjected to various forms
of discrimination
and sometimes even worse. And so, many
of the heretics in the empire, the
Christians whose faith was not orthodox,
they left and went east to Iraq and
Arabia.
And there, they taught their heresies
without having to worry about the Roman
authorities. And so, they would teach
Jesus is not divine.
And then, [snorts] it's in the Quran,
Jesus is not divine, and Jesus did not
rise from the dead, and so on and so on.
And so, it seems as if that
along with this creedally vague
monotheism that was already there among
the Arabs
was then
in the context of a dispute toward the
end of the century between Abd al-Malik
and Hajjaj and Abd al-Malik, I'm sorry,
and Abdullah ibn Zubayr on the other
side who was a rival for the leadership
of the Arabs
that they started to speak about the
praised one, Muhammad, as a separate
individual
and as a prophet and to construct a
religion based around him built on this
strict monotheism that had already
existed. And they did so because in
those days
the the the great empires were held
together by a religion. They didn't have
constitutions and parliaments. The unity
and they weren't ethnically unified. The
Romans were unified around Christianity.
The Persians, the other great empire of
the day, was unified were unified around
Zoroastrianism.
The Arabs conquered all this territory
and had this huge empire.
And then Abd al-Malik is dealing with
the threat from Abdullah and so he
starts to try to unify the people
around
>> [snorts]
>> this strict monotheism centered on this
person of Muhammad who may have been a
historical figure about was known
or
somebody that they started to tell
stories about for whatever reason that
people do that sort of thing and myths
grow like King Arthur and Robin Hood and
so on. And this began to grow and became
the way in the first place that he after
he beat Abdullah, how Abd al-Malik
unified his empire and held it together
by making this religion and making it
the foundation of the unity of the
empire and making it martial and violent
because these were all warriors who were
doing this.
And that seems to be where it comes
from.
So, the Quran itself, what was the
impetus for the
initial writing of the Quran? The word I
mean, I've I've I've interviewed um
Gabriel Reynolds about this and he has a
really interesting theory about how
there were multiple editors of of the
Quran itself based on the doublets.
Yeah. And uh he he's got a very
interesting theory, but what is your
view on how what why the Quran was uh
started to to be, you know, being
written in the first place? Well, I
believe that large portions of the Quran
seem to have existed before Islam. There
was a interesting thing. I wrote I wrote
a book uh about these issues, if you
will pardon the plug, Did Muhammad
Exist? Wrote it first about 2010.
And uh
around 2015 or so or so
later than that even, there was some big
discovery
>> [snorts]
>> of The Birmingham Are you talking about
the Birmingham? Yeah, that was uh
carbon dated to 570 to 645 and of of
Quran manuscripts and people were saying
people were writing to me, Muslims, and
saying, "Are you going to retract your
book and apologize now? Because we have
Muhammad's own Quran that he held in his
hand." That this was being trumpeted as.
But [snorts] the carbon dating actually
was from 570
to 645.
Muhammad is supposed to become a prophet
and start getting the Quran in 610. So,
570 to 610, if that's possible, means
that the the alleged Quran manuscript
actually predated
Muhammad and Islam
and is not a Quran at all.
And Christoph Luxenberg, the great
pseudonymous scholar of Syriac
has stripped away the diacritical marks
that we already discussed were not
original to the Quran anyway. And he
repoints the Quran manuscripts
in Aramaic and finds that a lot of the
passages that are sort of chaotic and
obscure in the Quran as it stands
suddenly become clear
when you read them as Aramaic.
This is extraordinary that
he posits that the word Quran, of
course, which means lectionary, is it's
called that because it was a lectionary.
But if you were to become a lector in
your parish then you're going to go up
and you're going to read the epistle.
And in the book, the lectionary,
there'll be the epistle [clears throat]
reading for the day.
And then there'll be the epistle reading
for the next day.
That might be from a completely
different book of the New Testament.
Mhm. Although usually they go in order
for a while and then skip to another
one. Mhm.
>> [clears throat]
>> But anyway
if the Quran's a lectionary, that
explains why it skips around with no
subject matter classifications, no rhyme
or reason to it. The Quran is not
arranged chronologically, the Quran is
not arranged thematically. There is no
arrangement to the Quran that's
discernable. But if it's a lectionary,
then suddenly that makes sense that you
have a reading for some time and then
the next reading for the next day or the
next week and the next reading. And so,
they might not have any connection with
one another. Anyway, this is something
that comes from Luxenberg's Luxenberg's
researches and
the idea is that the Quran was cobbled
together from various extant materials
which also would explain why it has
passages from the Bible
not passages, stories from the Bible. No
no uh
textual dependence, just stories heard,
overheard, and repeated, half repeated,
mangled, altered, various things. But
you have passages from the Bible, you
have
material from Jewish sources, you have
material from Zoroastrian sources, and
it's all mashed up
together
to create
the new [snorts] holy book cuz when
you're making a religion, you got to
have a holy book. Religions got holy
books. The Christians have the Bible,
the Jews have the Bible, too, but it's a
little bit different. The Persians have
the What is it? The Zend Avesta? And so,
you make a scripture.
But you make it out of material that
already exists.
And you alter it as needed.
So, that material, where did it
originally come from? Maybe Maybe I
missed it. Maybe you already went over
this.
>> Yeah, it's Jewish material,
it's Zoroastrian material, and some of
it is a Christian lectionary and some of
it is material from other sources.
>> From From these heretical Christians?
Yeah, some of it is from the heretical
Christians, which is why you have this
these ideas of Jesus. The very first
thing I wrote about Islam
in 1983,
I guess it was. Um Well. I wrote a paper
on the uh
they did not kill nor crucify him, but
it appeared so to them. Mhm. It's
[clears throat] chapter 4 verse 157 of
the Quran about Jesus that they did not
kill or crucify him, but the Jews
thought they'd crucified him. And I
traced that to there's not a there's not
a literary there's not a um
mention of this. It was just
speculation, but it is noteworthy that
the Gnostic several Gnostic material
Gospels and Gnostic documents.
You know Gnostic Christianity? It was a
Christian heresy.
>> And they believed that matter is evil
and that Jesus is the savior who comes
and he's not really real. You can pass
your hand right through him. This is why
John in the Epistle of John it says,
"That which was from the beginning which
we have heard, which we have seen with
our eyes."
"Which we have touched with our hands."
He has to emphasize that because the
Gnostics were saying he was just a
ghost. You could pass your hand right
through him. You wouldn't touch him cuz
he did not have physical
being because matter is evil.
All right? So, the Gnostics were
teaching this stuff and they're the
Second Treatise of the Great Seth is a
Gnostic document that has Jesus
laughing while Judas is being crucified.
Not Judas Iscariot, but Judas Thomas the
Twin.
Thomas called the Twin, one of the 12.
The doubter. And he's being crucified in
this Gospel while Jesus is up above, the
pure spirit with no body, and he's
laughing at them cuz they're so stupid
and they took the twin took his twin for
himself.
So, anyway, this is Gnostic Christianity
and this seems to be what was picked up
in early Islam that Jesus is
he just seemed to be in a body and was
not really was not actually crucified.
This is something they took over from
the Gnostics. And so, you have this kind
of thing being taken from various
sources and all put together, jumbled up
with no apparent attempt to organize it
in any way.
But just bits taken from here and there.
I mean, if you believe that Muhammad
actually originated the Quran, then
you've got to believe he was an
extraordinarily strange person, which of
course is perfectly reasonable
cuz Islam is extraordinarily strange.
But you read the Quran straight and you
read it attentively, you find that it
skips from one subject to another with
no rhyme or reason, with no explanation,
with no possible connection between the
two sections within chapters. It's not
like
chapter three's is all about X and
chapter four is all about Y. It's that
this part of chapter three is all about
X and then the next part is all about Y
and the next part is all about Q and it
just flies from one thing to another
with no connection whatsoever, which
would make sense if you've got a group
of people or various groups of people
sticking in parts that they wanted.
Does that make sense also? I mean this
is this is one thing that's really
appealing to me with the respect to the
Islamic dilemma. Is that why you think
something like the Islamic dilemma is
even a thing? Is because
Precisely. Because one group of people
thinks that their book
confirms the Torah and the Gospel. So
they stick that in.
And they don't have any idea cuz they
don't have they haven't had
acquaintance with the actual Torah and
Gospel because written books are not so
easy to come by when you have to copy
each one out by hand.
And so that's one thing and then you
have another group that may have
encountered or knows Christians or
something and has knows that these
things don't correspond. And so they
have to start saying you corrupted your
scriptures, which of course as you know
is not actually in the Quran, but it's
very strong in Islamic tradition cuz
it's the only thing that explains away
these passages.
This this does have some some really
strong
I think explanatory power. It can
explain all all of the weird
passages that we find in the Quran like
Sura 9:30 about Ezra and Jews
worshipping Ezra.
It's like where where did that come
from? Like where where
Well, nobody actually knows. It's
possible that there was some group of
Jews that were revering Ezra in some way
that have completely died out. That
seems most least likely though.
What is more likely is that this is a
misunderstood
passage from something or other just
like they misunderstand the Trinity and
think that it's Allah, Jesus, and Mary.
Mhm. That this is some misunderstood
reference to Ezra having some status or
other that they don't understand or
a mistranslation
or mis- misinterpretation
based on
faulty pointing based on the wrong
diacritical marks being put down, you
see.
Or
some combination of these things.
>> [snorts]
>> Ooh, this is just really
um
If I was a Muslim, I would be very
troubled. I mean even just in this this
uh
what we've covered so far. This is just
really troubling stuff. Maybe maybe we
can kind of shift gears and we can bring
it back to the the topic of whether or
not Muhammad existed and there's there's
two arguments I want to put forward. Um
I won't give them both at one time to to
overwhelm you like I did that other
question.
So the first one is and this one this
one just occurred to me. So it it may
not be that great, but um
if there is suppose that the Hadith
literature is unreliable. Okay, suppose
that and that's what that's basically
what you've argued. Um you've argued
obviously more than that, but the Hadith
literature let's take it for granted
that it's unreliable. Isn't it still
some kind of evidence that there was a
person named Muhammad that did some
stuff back then even if all of the
literature that the Hadith literature is
unreliable like they were still trying
to
get back to this original person because
that person actually existed. There's
[snorts] some evidence from the Hadith
literature. They're not trying to get
back obviously
or they'd be well, they are trying,
yeah. Because they are trying by means
of the isnad chains to get back to the
original stories. Yes, that is true. At
the same time with the legendary
elaboration, they're moving even farther
away from the possibility of doing that.
But yeah, like I said before, there may
have been some guy, but the question is
whether he's like King Arthur or Well,
actually I think
>> Santa Claus. Yeah, Santa Claus. That's a
good one. That King Arthur seems to have
actually existed. But the round table,
the knights, Guenevere and Lancelot and
all that stuff, there's no basis to
believe any of that actually happened.
Maybe some of it did.
But it's much more likely that whatever
King Arthur was in real life, he became
for whatever reason because he's
foundational to the English story or
whatever, he became the hanger on which
all these stories get hung and
they get passed down to us in that form,
but that doesn't mean they have any
historical value.
Or
Muhammad could be like Santa Claus.
Well, actually there was a Saint
Nicholas. There was a Saint Nicholas,
yeah. I was going to say. He was known
for his generosity and that's why these
stories get attached to him. So there
you go. Maybe we're maybe there really
was, but I mean of course there are
plenty of fictional characters that we
can name. The other objection, the other
sort of pushback I can offer which it's
along the lines of what you encountered
in your debate with David where there's
all of these embarrassing stories about
Muhammad in the Hadith, but then also in
the Quran itself like there seems to be
the the adopted son story.
Um there's just a lot of weird
embarrassing stuff.
I thought okay, so my cards on the
table. I I don't really buy that
argument. I think that you had a really
good response to David in in your
debate. So I'm not I'm not on David's
side with this one, but maybe maybe we
can kind of flush that a little bit more
here. Why don't you think those
embarrassing stories
tell us that there was a real historical
person
that that was named Muhammad that
actually did these things because the
criteria of embarrassment, you know,
with respect to the Gospels. If you guys
have have never heard of this sort of
historical criteria, um the the women
are the first ones to have stumbled upon
the empty tomb, but in those times a
woman's testimony was not as trusted as
a man's and so that's a quote unquote
embarrassing detail that actually lends
historical credibility to those accounts
being accurate that there was actually
women that saw it first. Um so then
switching back to Muhammad, there was
all these embarrassing stories about
Muhammad in the Quran and I'm sure that
you can spell some of those out for us.
Um but yeah, why don't those also lend
credibility to
the existence of such a person? Yeah.
Uh oh, sorry. I just got to get you back
here. I
jostled my screen and you vanished.
There you are. Um the
criteria of the criterion of
embarrassment
is
one that is sort of culturally tone deaf
with all respect because it assumes that
what embarrasses us would embarrass the
people in the 9th century.
And that's not necessarily the case.
So for example, you know, uh David David
of course is a
brilliant man and he The guy is
brilliant. I mean he and he's also just
like fun to listen to and I loved the
fact that in y'all's debate you were
like laughing at at the way that he was
presenting and stuff cuz you just like
appreciated his genius, yeah. I wish I
could be as a tenth as funny as David
is. And he had the whole crowd laughing
and me laughing when he's talking about
the stories of Aisha scraping the semen
off Muhammad's clothes. And you you got
to think, you know, why on earth would
anybody want to fabricate? And of course
we should remember that I'm not saying
these stories were necessarily
fabricated. That they may have been
amalgamated from a number of earlier
sources such that there really was
somebody
whoever he may have been who these
stories were passed on about and his his
child bride scraped semen off his
clothes.
But why would anybody pass that on?
And so David's argument is it had to
have happened. And they passed it on
because they felt duty bound to do so
because otherwise they would not be
preserving an authentic story about
their prophet.
The
ain't necessarily so aspect of that is
that
there's nothing necessarily embarrassing
about it. If you are a seventh century
person uh a male who values
being a male and thinks that and doesn't
have
21st century mores or even and much less
Christian morality.
And so you think this guy is constantly
being covered with semen. He's a real
man. He's just positively flowing in it.
It's always gushing out of him because
he's so manly. Wow, I want to be like
that.
Why not?
What can you say? Can you say, "Well,
no, that wouldn't have happened. That
couldn't have happened." No, you can't.
And I can't say that it did either
except that we know that Christian
morality didn't prevail in those areas
at that time. That this is indeed a
religion that is deeply centered upon
sex and has a very different idea of
morality from Christian morality such
that even paradise is just having sex
all the time.
And when you consider that that and it's
the highest good that they're offering
to human beings,
then it becomes a very different kind of
story.
And so what we're what I'm saying in
general and what people who hold to this
view are saying in in is that the
embarrassing stories are not necessarily
embarrassing to people of the time.
Even down to marrying Aisha at 6 years
old
>> Yes, sure. Especially if you want to
marry a 6-year-old, then it's very
convenient for you that you have a
prophet who did this, who's the
excellent example that you should
emulate.
And so if anybody possibly objects and
says, "You shouldn't marry a
6-year-old." Then you say, "Well,
Muhammad did it. How could it be wrong?
He's the excellent example."
And so that's precisely the kind of
story that you would want to have in
there
if you were so inclined.
Mhm.
Yeah, see I think I think that pushback
does make a lot of sense. You got to
jump into the mind of a 6th century, 7th
century, 8th century, maybe 9th century
Arab, right? And you've got to get into
their mindset as opposed to looking at
it what through our lens, through our
cultural lens, and looking back at it be
like, "That's embarrassing stuff." Which
you know, it is to to us, but back then
maybe not.
And you mentioned um
the daughter-in-law. And that is a story
that's kind of unique
in Islamic literature. For those who
don't know,
I'll just tell the story very briefly.
Uh Muhammad had an adopted son,
Zaid. And he had a wife,
Zaynab, who was very beautiful.
Muhammad one day goes to see Zaid, and
he ain't home. And Zaynab, because she
is used to thinking that this is like
her father, it's her father-in-law, and
they're all one big happy family, she
answers the door in a state of
semi-undress.
Muhammad is overcome with her beauty,
goes away saying, "Glory to God for
creating all this great beauty." And so
on. He's very flustered, he's very
upset. And Zaid, who doesn't get along
so well with Zaynab, he goes and says,
"How about I divorce her and you marry
her?"
And Muhammad says, "No, keep your wife
and fear Allah."
And then later then Muhammad gets a
revelation where Allah says, "Why do you
want to not get take what I want to give
you?
And when you said keep your wife and
fear Allah, you were going against what
I wanted to give you."
And so he wakes up from his trance and
he tells people, "Who will go tell
Zaynab that Allah has married her to
me?"
And people were upset and said, "How
could he have married his
daughter-in-law?" And so in order to
alleviate the scandal,
Allah
forbids adoption.
And so Zaid is no longer his adopted
son.
Zaynab is no longer his daughter-in-law.
Everything's okay.
And so people throughout history,
Christians and others have said, "You
see, you're you're you're
uh you're revering this immoral man,
this lecherous, lustful man as a
prophet."
And so that's been embarrassing in the
story itself. People were talking about
it, and that's why Allah forbade
adoption.
And
later on in history people talk about it
and embarrass Muslims about it to this
day.
However, even this story
could very easily have been invented for
other purposes
or appropriated for other purposes. The
Quran tells the story in chapter 33.
And it tells it very elliptically. It
does not just tell the story in a
straightforward manner. It acts as if
you already know the story. It forbids
adoption a couple times.
Uh and then it
says, "And when you I'll I'll actually
read it. I have it open here.
It says uh "And when you said to him on
whom Allah has conferred favor, and you
have conferred favor, keep your wife to
yourself and fear Allah. And you hid in
your mind what Allah was going to bring
to light, and you feared mankind,
whereas Allah has a better right that
you should fear him.
So when Zaid had performed that
necessary formality from her, we gave
her to you in marriage, so that there
may be no sin for believers in regard to
the wives of their adopted sons. So this
is all about forbidding adoption,
supposedly. But then it goes on and in
verse 40 it says, "Muhammad is not the
father of any of your men, but he is the
messenger of Allah and the seal of the
prophets." Now, that doesn't go with the
story at all. The story has nothing to
do with Muhammad being the messenger of
Allah or the seal of the prophets. So
was it just stuck there randomly, that
verse? As I said before, all sorts of
things are stuck everywhere in the Quran
randomly. Maybe.
>> [clears throat]
>> Or
or
it could be actually part of the story
and the whole point of the story.
And the point of the story would then be
that Muhammad is not the father of any
of your men, whether natural or adopted,
cuz he had no natural sons that survived
to adulthood.
And that as he is not the father of any
of your men, he's the seal of the
prophets. Because in the Quran, all the
prophets are related.
And the prophetic spirit is thus passed
on genetically. So if Muhammad had a
son,
he would have been a prophet. If you
want to say Muhammad is the last
prophet, he can't have any sons.
So this whole story is all about how he
doesn't have any sons. Therefore, he's
the last prophet. It's designed to
prevent other prophets from arising in
the Islamic community and splitting it.
But then why have him marry his adopted
son's wife? So that you know that
there's not even adoption. That he can't
even have an adopted son.
There is no son of any kind for
Muhammad. So he's the last prophet,
therefore. Couldn't you couldn't he
though have gotten gotten rid of
adoption and then not married her?
Yeah, sure.
But the whole point is that he got rid
of adoption to marry her.
He has to have a reason [clears throat]
to get rid of adoption. Otherwise, it's
just out of the blue.
Mhm. Okay, I see. Otherwise, he's uh
he's just getting rid of adoption for
the sake of it. I guess he I guess he
still could have done that.
Well, sure.
Uh we could speculate on all kinds of
things he could have done. But my point
is only that there is the possibility
that this whole story was created in
order to
emphasize that Muhammad is the seal of
the prophets, which is something that
all of Islamic tradition is deeply
concerned about. Because then they know,
see any kind anybody who declares
themself a prophet could then become a
new power center, and there could be a
revolution, there could be a splitting
of the kingdom, there could be of the
caliphate that is, there could be a uh
a civil war.
But if you know ipso facto, right away,
you know without any shadow of a doubt
that anybody who says he's a prophet
after Muhammad is not,
then you can nip those movements in the
bud and preserve the unity of the
community, which they've succeeded in
doing actually largely
uh throughout history.
So maybe one more uh question and then
we'll start to to wrap things up here.
So um what what about the account and
I'm terrible with references, so uh
you'll have to help me with this one.
The account of him getting more wives in
the Quran, where does that occur? Cuz
that that also seems kind of
embarrassing along the same lines. Yeah.
There is a passage.
I'm blanking on where it is myself right
now, but it does say that the prophet
gets more wives than the ordinary
believers.
And what I am positing is that this
material was amalgamated together from
material involving a lot of different
people.
And so there may have been somebody who
was claiming to be a prophet who got the
permission to have more wives than other
people.
It may have been that some ruler
thought, "I need to get more wives than
other people, and I'm not a prophet, but
I can extrapolate from Muhammad getting
permission
to have more wives than ordinary
people." Or something of that kind.
But in any case, the fact that we have
the Quran saying that and Islamic
tradition saying that Muhammad did
indeed have more wives than were allowed
for the average Muslim man, does not
necessarily mean this that Muhammad is
historical. It could be that the story
of Muhammad is constructed so that he
has more wives than the average Muslim
man because that is a text in the Quran.
And so I mean, there are plenty of
stories
in the Quran
>> [clears throat]
>> where there are two different
explanations in the Hadith,
which militates against the idea that
either one of them is the real
explanation.
Uh
what I mean is
there is asbab al-nuzul literature all
through the Hadith.
The asbab al-nuzul is the circumstances
of revelation.
So you have a Quran passage, there's a
whole literature of the circumstances
[snorts]
in Muhammad's life
that gave rise to this Quran passage.
And that's the asbab al-nuzul. So
in many cases, you have more than one.
And neither both neither
both are likely to not be true, but they
can't both be true.
One might be true and the other not, or
they're both not true, but they're
not [snorts] likely to be both true. And
I can give you an example in a minute.
But
that's what I'm saying about this, that
it's possible that a great deal of the
life of Muhammad as it come now stands
was
created or altered in order to fit
what ended up in the Quran.
So you have the Quran saying he's got
more wives, you got to get a story where
he's got more wives or several stories.
So that it fits.
What I'm referring to about there being
different stories, take for example
chapter 66.
Um
and I'll get it here real quick.
Chapter 66 at the beginning says this,
"O prophet, why do you prohibit what
Allah has made lawful to you?" See there
again, just like in 33, he's always
saying, "Oh, I don't want to have what
Allah wants me to have."
Trying to please your wives. And Allah
is forgiving, merciful. Allah has made
lawful for you absolution from your
oaths.
And Allah is your protector. He is the
knower, the wise one. When the prophet
confided a fact to one of his wives, and
when she afterward revealed it, and
Allah told him about this, he made part
of it known and passed over a part. And
when he told it to her, she said, "Who
has told you?" He said, "The knower, the
aware, has told me." If you two turn in
repentance to Allah for what your hearts
desired, and if you help one another
against him, then indeed even he is his
protecting friend, and Gabriel and the
righteous among the believers, and
furthermore the angels are his helpers.
It may happen that his Lord, if he
divorces you, will give him in your
place wives who are better than you,
Muslim, believing, pious, penitent,
devout, inclined to fasting, widows and
maidens. All right. So that's the that's
the passage from the Quran chapter 66.
And the standard explanation is that
Muhammad was going out, and this is
based on a Hadith, Muhammad was going
around to his wives in an order.
Everyone [snorts]
has a night, you know?
Like, "Oh, it's Tuesday, that's Aisha.
It's Wednesday, that's Hafsa. It's
Thursday, that's Zaynab, whoever." So
>> [clears throat]
>> he skips a night, he skips a girl and
goes to sleep with Mary the Copt, his
slave girl.
And the wives get mad at him.
So Allah comes to save the day and tells
them, "Hey, you better back off or he'll
divorce you and I'll give him better
wives."
Okay? But there's a whole other story in
other Hadith
where Muhammad is sneaking honey. It has
nothing to do with going around on the
behind the back of his wives. He's
sneaking honey and it gives him bad
breath, and he told them he wouldn't eat
honey.
So he goes and sneaks honey, and they
get mad,
and Allah threatens them that he'll
divorce them.
Now,
seems to me when you have two wildly
divergent stories like that, most likely
they're both made up to explain this
elliptical these elliptical references
in the Quran. The Quran's referring to
something. We don't have any idea what,
and neither do the people who write the
Hadith, and they come up with two wildly
different stories to explain it.